but you know who doesn't understand
something Donald Trump and to be honest
Donald Trump doesn't understand a lot of
things but now he's mad because he
doesn't understand Google he doesn't
know exactly how search engines work and
because of that there is now likely to
be an investigation coming from the
White House into the alleged suppression
of pro-trump news on Google here is what
started all of this nonsense this is the
tweet from Donald Trump it's actually
it's a two-part tweet because he had a
lot to say here here it is Google search
results for quote Trump news shows only
the viewing reporting of fake news media
in other words they have it rigged for
me and others so that almost all stories
and news is bad fake CNN as prominent
Republican conservative and fare media
shut out illegal 96% of results on quote
trump news from national left-wing media
very dangerous Google and others are
suppressing voices of conservatives and
hiding information and news that is good
they are controlling what we can and
cannot see this is a very serious
situation will be addressed shortly
after our Google e challenged President
issued those tweets Larry Kudlow the
economic adviser to the president went
on TV and he said you know what yeah
we're probably gonna have to investigate
this here's what you're going to be
investigating cut low and White House
investigators if you're listening I hope
you are you're going to be investigating
why the president doesn't know how to
use Google I'm going to go ahead and
give you a quick primer mr. Trump in
case you're watching or in case one of
your aides wants to show you this and
here it is when you want to look up news
for something some topic some person
whatever it is you don't have to add
news to your search term okay if you're
on Google when you type it in and you
hit go the top is usually where the news
is found then if you want more news or
just only news
you just click on the little tab that
says news it's it's it's real easy I'm
sure Baron would absolutely be able to
show you how to do this if you ever
wanted to spend any time with your own
child
and maybe have a little father-son
bonding time there you know something
something nice do a family thing and
have Barron teach you how to use the
Internet but here's what's so ridiculous
not just that the president doesn't know
how to use Google I get it guys in his
mid seventies you know he didn't grow up
with computers like a lot of us it's
easy to make fun of that and we should
probably feel a little sorry for him we
have wasted so much time and so much
money just in the last few months of
conservatives having to investigate
social media now Google everything that
they claim has some kind of bias against
Republicans and conservatives and their
media outlets I mean we had diamond and
silk have to come before Congress to
talk about their terrible plight of
their Facebook page getting shut down
we had Mark Zuckerberg have to go before
the Senate to talk about all of this as
well as obviously you know other
countries using his platform to
influence elections that was actually
the main reason he was there but that
became the secondary thought they wanted
to talk about Facebook censoring
conservative voices allegedly then
thought it always gets so much worse
we've got conservatives on Twitter
whining about allegedly being shadow
banned and anytime they tweet about how
they are shadow banned it gets thousands
upon thousands of retweets and likes
which isn't something that could happen
if you were actually shadow banned all
of this began from conspiracy theories
spread from right-wing news sites PJ
Media is actually one of the ones that
kind of started all of this saying they
were burying pro-trump news look you
want to see positive news out there
Donald
do something positive do something that
actually helps the majority of people in
this cut
three and something that isn't a lie if
you do that then maybe next time you go
on to the google and type in Trump News
you'll see a headline that says hey
Donald Trump did something that wasn't
completely stupid we have to take a
quick break we'll be right back I'm
pleased to tell you that today's show is
underwritten by better help.com slash
Pakman therapy is important we have a
real crisis in our country not just
people who could benefit from mental
health services but the stigma that
surrounds mental health services and as
many people in the audience know lots of
people in my family work in the field of
mental health and I have made it a
mission of the show to at any
opportunity make clear that there is
absolutely no shame whatsoever in going
to talk to someone when you feel that
that's the right thing to do and that's
what better help provides you get a
fully licensed and experienced
psychologists and therapists through
videophone and text it's less expensive
than meeting in person with a counselor
after three months the price goes down
even more but you get the same
professional service that you would from
going into somebody's office and you
also get unlimited access you can speak
to a counselor every day if you want
signing up is easy you go to better help
calm slash pakman fill out a
questionnaire they will pair you with a
therapist that works for you but you're
always able to switch to somebody else
if there's a better fit available go to
better help calm slash Pakman it's so
easy to sign up and get started we're
putting a link in the description if
you're watching this on YouTube it is
better help calm slash PA que ma N